I'd like to think that I'm realistic
which means that the optimism is only
justified if a few people take very
strong action sometimes putting
themselves at their careers at risk and
then you will see this positive feedback
loop where more people get inspired by
this and I mentioned some of the people
that have inspired me that have taken
their family disease and become
healthcare activists if we have a few
activists it doesn't have to be
everybody um but everybody should join
with them and doing their little part so
i think that's that would lead to
optimism but i'm not going to be blindly
optimistic we need to have activists and
people who get inspired by activists
good certainly in the i would say in the
short term but since these are
exponential technologies it's actually a
very long time in say an internet time
ok is that we will I think that most
people will get access to their genetic
information a lot of people will want it
and they will get it this will be a
little probably affordable this year so
that's not you know it's not very long
even an Internet time but then to get it
interpreted they'll have to share I
don't know exactly how that work out but
I see trends towards sharing you know
Wikipedia you know the Red Cross all
kinds of things an old and new that
indicate that at least a significant
fraction the population will share their
their genes their environment and their
traits that will lead us to a point
where and I also see that stem cells
where you can take a bit of skin and
reprogram it so then you can get access
to any tissue in your body that's coming
down just in a few years then using that
to fix what's going on in adult aging so
you actually stay youthful for a longer
period of time not necessarily
eliminating aging but certainly
increasing our that quality of life I
think that will
happen and that will have a huge impact
because there's a certain wisdom that
will happen when healthy people stay
healthy and engaged for a long period of
time one of them another one of the
things that makes humans fairly amazing
is that they do live for a long time
well past what would have been their
reproductive limit in ancient days
because you know grandparents and
great-grandparents and business leaders
and so forth add value that goes beyond
the reproductive years and I think that
if we can make those very healthy and
very undistracted by by health issues
that would be a huge change in the
future and then if we have computers
robots humans acting all acting as
supercomputers and geniuses we have a
plan full of six billion people with
each with six billion supercomputers
then you can no longer predict I mean
that's a that's a fairly rosy picture
but at that point you don't know where
it goes
flash mode now this is not a political
scientist speaking so you get taken as a
great insult but it's but from my biased
viewpoint a lot of the political
problems have to do with the haves and
the have-nots and we have seen many
examples of the rising tide floating all
the boats of where there's more people
in the middle class than there ever was
in past history so if if that trend can
continue then there will be fewer people
who feel like they represent a
underprivileged class now they're still
our there's still our cultural
differences that even the two different
wealthy people can have major cultural
differences of opinion but perhaps those
will be mitigated by having bite by some
embracement of diversity I mean we'll
just have to see I mean it certainly
will change the technology will change
the way that people interact politically
but it's very hard to predict exactly
that time it's not inevitable because
right now it's it's a trade-off between
curing poverty and sending very
expensive space missions out there and I
wish there weren't it weren't a economic
trade off we will probably do both as we
have but it would be great if we cured
poverty and then used all those
resources those additional minds and so
forth to help us get off the planet but
I think sub / orbital is is very far
stretch from where we need to go because
out there is a lot of radiation and a
lot of particles that will destroy any
rapidly moving device and everything in
it and so we need to build a it's a very
challenging task to be able to build you
know space elevators build very thin
devices that are very robust
us that would not be affected by space
particles or build very large devices
that will not be affected by radiation
because like the Earth's atmosphere they
provide you know many meters of
protection from cosmic radiation so I
think these are things are not commonly
discussed even getting to Mars is
extraordinarily expensive undertaking
getting to something outside of our
solar system is almost beyond fastening
from an economic standpoint and it
really requires we have all the rest of
our economics I think in good shape